and while it may be a little more
challenging this year the staff at las
vegas weekly
has some tips for you to keep the
holidays special joining us now with
some insight is cindy moon read
hi cindy hey how's it going good to see
you
good to see you from baking to crafts
you have some
simple ways for us to safely celebrate
with our kids what can you share
it's all about enjoying the holiday
while staying safe so that includes
just a mix of doing things at home such
as like
diy ornaments we have instructions for
like how to make
salt dough ornaments in the magazine
there's even
a there's even a couple recipes for
christmas cookies
there are some places like uh
there's open art las vegas and the arts
factory that you can actually
do uh arts and crafts classes through
them
online so you can kind of connect while
being
safe we also recommend doing things like
creating
a a family virtual greeting card
and in this case uh your children are
probably
tech savvier than you yeah so
so maybe ask their advice for what they
can do
um regarding like making a tick tock
card or putting together like
a video slideshow um something
that you know you can kind of let the
children take
charge but also have it be a family
activity you can do together
i like this idea as well in addition to
using the photos for a slideshow you
talk about bringing out the old photo
albums and telling family stories
to really help kids know their lineage a
little better a bit better and about
their ancestors and you also talk about
ancestors
getting to know your family history
through some of those websites we've
heard before
great ideas for families to take a look
back
yeah i think it's a good chance we'll
kind of we're stuck at home
to to really do both the online you can
go to ancestry.com
or similar websites but also do
the the old school photo albums
tell stories tell family stories
associated with those photos
if your children can't see your family
members in person
you could even do a zoom family share
event so this is your chance to connect
with those people that you might not
have even had a chance to connect with
anyway so no now time or
distance is no longer a problem that's
the one good side
cindy we got to wrap it up here great
ideas i also like that you said hey
maybe a time to play chess inspired by
the queen's gambit on netflix that's a
way to connect what apparently what
everyone's watching
to maybe a new hobby right and if it's
not too on the nose there's a board game
called pandemic
oh my goodness maybe maybe too soon
we'll give it a whirl cindy thanks for
your time we look forward to having you
in studio
in the new year kirsten